and then in high school you have to do
the hard work of staying connected with
them I mean I think a lot of parents
think oh in high school that's where
it's really going to get hard most of
the worldview installation is done by
High School your job then is to maximize
your emotional connection because there
are influences that are seeking to
relationally pull them away I mean all
of our kids have experience that you
just have to double down and make sure
that your emotional connection is even
stronger that's really hard when you've
got more than one kid when they're in
high school when they're busy but that
is for us that's where you put all your
chips in high school